how often do you
know
when you've got the right person it's
more that sometimes we just get the
excitement of like oh this landed
because we'll listen to the same scene
again and again and again and again you
know what i heard this for the first
time just now in that actor
yeah because there are a lot of people
who could do it like who you know they
come in they do a fine job and they
could do it and then there are people
who come and sort of like add something
to it they're like oh okay now this has
layers or something something we just or
something you just didn't they mine
something
out of it that you didn't know they
could it's not about how to say
something it's sort of why you're saying
something and you can talk about why
easily and you can talk about why
beforehand and getting into how is is
sort of too present tense for like i
think real performance if we are casting
non-actors to cast them with
uh more experienced actors because i do
think that that balance
and it's really helpful easier to do in
film than it is to do in tv when you're
casting real people
you really do need to meet them in the
room you can't really just cast off your
tape
because you need to get a vibe if you're
sending a crazy person to set or not and
you might i mean some people some of the
people who like real people like like
the crazy like the crazy person but you
need to know what you're sending i think
it's such an important thing is like
know when you're sending a crazy person
does that